what do you know about the sierra  program  reckless mystery man you guys send in  when you can officially send anyone else  the great man  lloyd  i got an urgent locate and destroy  that could be fun the man's got some  street cred  [Music]  you're hurt  i mean my ego's a little bruised  they'll have something they really want  what's your gut it's gonna be my funeral  you're going to next  you want to make an omelet  you got to kill some people  you must be loyal or gave it away the  trash dash it's just it leans lloyd  i'm about to put a hit so big on your  boy's head  that even his most loyal allies don't  hesitate to drop an eye  every grade a wet team from here to  rachel  will be vying for the prestige of  killing the infamous year six  they can kill anybody  maybe not anybody  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you